so let's say that this is a cell
so we know that all sorts of activity is
going on inside of this cell here and we
will study that in a lot more depth as
we go further in our study of biology
but it's important to realize that this
cell and the activity in that cell is
not operating in isolation
that in order to
live that cell needs resources from the
outside world so resources need to make
their way through that outer membrane of
the cell so it can be used inside that
cellular machinery and as that cell does
what it does it's also going to generate
waste products and that needs to be
released somehow across that membrane so
you also have waste
and you also have energy that is going
to be transferred either from the inside
of the cell to the outside or from the
outside to the inside a lot of times we
imagine that all of the activity inside
of the cell is generating thermal energy
that has to be dissipated somehow and
that is usually the case not always
and so
you have thermal energy
that has to be dissipated
now you might see something interesting
or maybe you haven't seen it just yet
is that you have all of this activity
operating in the volume of the cell but
then all of this exchange all of the
resources coming in the waste coming out
the thermal energy going in either
direction it has to be somehow diffused
across this surface across this
two-dimensional surface
so this raises an interesting question
as our volume increases what happens to
the ratio of our surface to our volume
because you could imagine maybe at some
point the volume gets large enough that
you don't have enough surface area to do
these three things well
and so let's think about this ratio
let's think about the ratio of our
surface area to volume and i'm going to
get a little bit mathy here you don't
have to know the math for the context of
a biology course but you need to know
what the conclusion is that the math is
going to give us so if this is a sphere
of radius
r
the surface area of this sphere
is going to be 4 pi r squared
and the volume of this sphere is going
to be four thirds pi
r cubed
so this pi would cancel with that pi if
we divide the numerator and denominator
by r squared we get a one there and then
we just get an r right over here if we
divide both of these by 4 you get a 1
there and this is going to be a 1 3 and
so we are going to be left with 1 over
1 3
r or we could just write this as this is
equal to 3 over r and so we see at least
for a spherical cell like this as r
increases as our cell gets larger and
larger the ratio between our surface
area to volume decreases so let me write
that as r
goes up
then the ratio between our surface area
to volume surface area to volume is
going to go down the bigger your
denominator the lower the value is going
to be and so what that tells us is is
that as the volume of our cell increases
as our cell gets bigger and bigger and
bigger we have less surface area per
unit of volume and so it's going to make
that exchange of the resources the waste
and that energy harder and harder and
harder and we would get a similar result
if instead of doing a spherical cell
let's say we did a cuboidal cell so
let's do it like this
a cuboidal cell you might see this in
some plants something that's roughly
cuboidal or rectangular in some way or
rectangular prism i should say but let's
say it's x by x
by x we could do the same exercise our
ratio of surface area to volume is going
to be what well our surface area you
have six faces that are each have an
area of x squared so our surface area is
going to be 6 x squared and then our
volume is going to be x times x times x
over x to the third and so this is going
to be divide the numerator and
denominator by x squared you get 6 over
x so once again you see that as x
increases
our ratio of surface area to volume
decreases as our denominator increases
well then that whole expression is going
to decrease
so given this phenomena it makes it hard
for larger and larger cells to exist
because for all the activity happening
in the volume they don't have enough
surface area to do all of this exchange
now there are things we see in
biological systems that help cells get
further than what we see here if you
imagine the two-dimensional
cross-section of this cell
one way to increase the surface area to
volume is for the membrane to look more
like this
the more folds you have
the higher surface area to volume that
you are going to have and you indeed see
this in a lot of biology anytime you
want a high surface area to volume you
tend to see things like these folds in
the membranes of the cells